Andrew we've seen protests before what's
different this time around in Hong Kong
and they have uh well they've got near
the central business district but now
they're basically three nucleuses to the
protest and the students who are running
who are the the energy of this protest
have kind of uh overwhelmed the original
organizers who had talked about a much
more reduced maybe 10 000 people
occupying Central not disrupting
business you know cooperating and now uh
the scale of this thing especially after
the the the clashes with police last
night and they used tear gas has just
mushroomed I just got back from the
protest there were easily 30 or 40 000
in the main point and like I said it
spread to two other parts of the city a
lot of the roads are closed although the
protesters are incredibly well behaved
they're really not confrontational
they're not damaging anything they're
not provoking the police in fact I was
just out there there were tens of
thousands of people there and I hardly
saw a police officer who was completely
peaceful I think the police kind of
learned last night that their tactics
backfired and they've really backed off
today I mean it is surprising I mean
having lived in Hong Kong and been born
there to see that happening on the
streets or even if they are relatively
mild compared to what we've seen in
other parts of the world but Andrew do
we know if that's going to carry on
later into the night and into tomorrow
how does it look so far
I would say tonight things are likely to
remain peaceful but you know no one
knows what the end game is here this
thing grew so much more quickly and was
so much more spontaneous than people had
anticipated because the Occupy Central
group had said basically they were going
to protest on Wednesday and Thursday on
public holidays of this week and then
the students moved in and kicked it off
and occupy had to drop their original
plan to join this process so it's
unclear the demands keep shifting uh you
know they would like free and open
elections it's very unlikely that
Beijing is going to turn around and say
oh sure no problem you can vote for
whoever you want that's that's uh really
kind of pie in the sky at this point but
now they're also asking for the chief
executive of Hong Kong to resign who is
backing the Beijing plan and I think the
police and probably the government is
looking for a way out now and trying to
figure out who they need to talk to to
negotiate but you know they're worried
this is a big week for Hong Kong
Shoppers this is golden week this is
when China's on vacation yep all right
Andrew we've got to leave it there but
thank you so much for joining us and
giving us another a collar that's
happening on the ground there in Hong
Kong Andrew Davis of Bloomberg News in
Hong Kong